hey hey dee would you be cool with uh
sam start only fans
i i mean i'm thinking about it literally
that's the whole time i've been like
i've been supportive this whole time
i've been telling you for a while to do
it yeah
over a year over here we just had to get
approval from your mom and papa
and they were cool with it they were
always they never had an issue with it
that's the thing
like i think it's just feet yeah they're
like it's just feet yeah okay
but we're going to go down a dark road
that's the only fence
oh yeah guys
what's the [ __ ] out of the cat that's
all here we go
finally kid 3d part two
yes went on a weird road damn you say
you
a year from now my guy's got news cat's
in rehab
you're going business but i'm more
nervous about that like yo where is this
going to leave
don't catch smart yeah cat's too smart
money is not but money
money is money problem the money thing
it's when it's more money
yeah are you talking about cat quitting
no just going crazy with it because it's
like
she's 10 here's the but she pulls it in
like a phantom like all right
that's not bad i come from like a family
or live
girls like vietnamese coffee shop girls
like i'm used to women
like using their bodies for money so
this isn't something
that's new to me what do they do at the
coffee shop so vietnamese coffee shops
are the one i told you it's like hooters
starbucks and a strip club had a baby
like skimpy dresses
lingerie clear heels serving coffee are
they open right now
yeah some of them are yes you know san
jose and orange county those are weird
wait what is this are you [ __ ] me
like this real quick
these are like my aunts my cousins
from rush hour i saw the tower rush hour
all the doors
dude that's crazy this is what i'm
talking about that's what i never had
to tell you something in arizona we have
this thing called bikini beans gosh yeah
it's like that it's
it's like that yeah girls in the shop
bikinis
hear me out here yeah you have your
money now i have my money
okay we opened up one of these coffee i
love coffee
i love it i love you asian
your badass sister's serving the java oh
i'm there
you gotta keep me happy you know right
right
yeah i'm sure you have other asian
friends yeah this is the in arizona
arizona oh no
no no no no no no you [ __ ] it up i'm
not trying to see
white girls open the videos it's an
asian
white girls those are white girls these
are those white girls
is not working at my place so you
discriminate
you can't have a flat ass and work at
the restaurant we run a tight ship here
we serve dark roasts and fat ass
asian only damn oh you want asian homie
all right
that's our thing no i like i like
i can't believe this exists and it's
just can you have
sex with them yeah uh that's the thing
no it's at the end of the day just a
coffee shop but whatever the girls
choose to do or not you is up for that
oh they have they have that i'll take it
from here cat
well if you want to get in the java room
yeah
why they serve you coffee oh yeah
they're barefoot
damn we usually wear clear heels clear
heels yeah
what you are with your side you can do
what you want
the job rooms barefoot barefoot barefoot
big tits
dark roast oh okay you don't have to
drink coffee right
uh can i just just show up and just [ __ ]
girls i don't
know hey man hey
this is a place of business with premium
now you have the strip club it's a two
drink minimum yeah you got to worse up
oh okay if you want a frappuccino we got
that oh any vip rooms any vip
that's the java room that's the java
room baby job room vip only
we offer subscriptions
you get a discount on cats only fans oh
two percent off
bro whatever kick you in the nuts for a
grand
[Laughter]
sure
your feet
i love this business adventure okay java
room yeah that should be popping in the
summertime
we have steve we have stevie running the
books
[Laughter]
he's very good
and you're serving coffee dude and you
have a convicted
felon running the books what are you
doing we hyped up
that's beautiful that's dope it'd be
dope right it wouldn't we probably
started something right now
yeah has not someone's probably gonna
take this yeah maybe like yeah they'll
call they but they don't have me and cat
oh yeah they can try and gotta have the
investment baby
they don't have the squad i got the
jewel over there but you had the oh and
you seen her sister
i know you've seen the sis
with the medusa you see the sis
can i throw something in there like a
loop you gotta have a cave baby in there
for the bread no we don't have uglies
what do you mean you have to have that
one nope not some dudes are into that
not at the java room
we ain't into it we ain't it like this
for the consumers
go somewhere else man
and i do call them [ __ ] and we pull
tips ladies we're not keeping your own
people tips everybody we all put the
tips
yeah i love this okay cats i'm steve
jobs it's like apples
bring it in i create the
clear heels on the outside barefoot on
the inside damn clear heel scat
clear
i want to see that commercial it's very
commercial how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son